alright guys this is my new celestron
next r8 telescope it is 8 inches across
and it can go up to magnification of
about 480 times right now the eyepiece I
have on is able to magnify images up to
120 times it's basically controlled with
this remote here and once you align it
to the stars then you can actually plug
in something that you'd like to see like
a certain star cluster or planet and it
will automatically it'll automatically
go to it sort of like a GPS system I
also have a laser sight that I could
basically look through it and just make
sure that it's in the general area of
what I'm trying to find so it's been
pretty cool as far as what I've been
able to see with it I don't know if
anyone has seen the pictures that I
originally posted on my channel but I
had some pictures of the Moon and also
Jupiter that I was able to take with it
so I did take some footage of the moon
tonight and I'd like to show you guys
what the moon looks like at about 120
times magnification